[Music]
foreign
and I've been working in United States
for over seven years now before moving
to United States I worked for data
consultancy services for about four
years
I believe in constant learning staying
relevant before enrolling in product
management program I completed my first
Stanford online course on turned data
into insights with predictive modeling I
was impressed by the platform engagement
and online resources that's when I
started browsing other available courses
or programs to expand my skill set when
I found this product management program
offered by Stanford I could relate it
with my current role and then where I
want to see myself in near future
Stanford is largest country's great
institution but well reputed across the
globe Stanford online didn't let it down
and exceeded the Expectations by the
finest online learning courses in
programs I have deepened my skills and
learnings which will eventually help me
to Advance my career
all the instructors made this program
engaged and exciting I really liked how
they have some real examples in
classroom training included in the
courses so if you're looking for highly
engaged courses I would say you should
go for Stanford online programs
[Music]